sur sept anciens courts de tennis se
dresse une yourte qui servira d'école
maternelle et de centres de loisirs tout
est encore en travaux mais à la rentrée
sera proposée une centaine d'activités
aux élèves
ici ce ne sera pas l'enseignant mais
chaque camp fronde qui décidera de son
emploi du temps et à son rythme
cette méthode baptisée montessori est
censé favoriser l'apprentissage ça va
être plus durable plus facile aussi plus
rapide parce que la mémoire s'active
quand il y à motivation
donc si l'enfant choisit en fonction de
là où on est sûr cerveau à ce moment là
il va viser juste il va apprendre avec
plaisir bien sûr il va être accompagné
par les adultes
en tout quatre éducatrices s'occuperont
des élèves de 3 à 6 ans réunis dans une
seule classe première école du genre en
eure et loir
elle va accueillir des enfants de tout
le département
d'où le choix de s'installer à luisant à
côté de chartres
l'idée c'était de pouvoir trouver un
lieu assez central et c'est vrai que
luisant chartres est plutôt à une zone
centrale en termes économiques en terme
de travail et en même temps on n'avait
pas envie d'être un centre ville dans la
mesure où l'écologie est le contact avec
la nature sont des points importants
pour nous les enfants seront en effet
sensibiliser à l'écologie
sur ce terrain boisé de 7000 m² le site
appartient à la mairie qui a soutenu ce
projet différent des écoles publiques et
privées classiques on a trouvé que ça
pouvait être une une alternative pour
certains enfants qui ont des difficultés
à s'intégrer dans les deux systèmes qui
cohabitent actuellement et on trouve un
truc c'était plutôt bien mais c'est vrai
que c'était un vrai débat au sein de la
municipalité puisque il ya des frais de
scolarité qui sont quand même conséquent
les parents devront en effet payer 375
euros par mois mais l'école compte déjà
plus d'une dizaine d'inscriptions
à terme elle pourra accueillir 24 à 28
enfants dans l'école maternelle